让我来告诉你一些真正的做自媒体的方法
你们学的那些乱七八糟的东西
我跟他说一大用的有
有那么一点点做的就这么一堆丢
不能再多了
你别不服啊
你看你是不是学什么定位
你上来订位
早做人数
对
怎么起号
怎么做高子怎么把用不细节
我感觉我要
给这条
就要被分
然后
然后有什么样的结果
对不对
结果你订了半天被定成他们吗
结果怎么样呢
你似有一堆人数
你自己都不好意思出现了你觉得太假了
是不是
然后突然有一个人
打他坐下来下面有一个人
一说你马上就不忙了
然后
好不一搞一个数据
按那个摩托板骗完了以后然后你还被搞着
你到庆头面前就发带
有没有
就算出来了你会发现每天都盲用那个选题呀
今天拍了以后
明天选题是啥呀
对不对
就算你坐起来了
我告诉你你也不会尝误的
为什么
因为那些所谓的技巧
所谓的方法论
都是可以扶持的
就今天你出了个包款
明天马上就快就快就快就快就扶持了
AI做的比你还好
然后你会发现你的那个赛料
你的那个方式是你那个方法
很快就特别特别用几
然后你的留下就被吸收了
原本这么大留下是帞这么点
然后朝鲍一退你发现我靠我帧国在左右
我不是在伙传不到
我我是没有朋友
千万女党会
就照样照样就不行了
所以到底该怎么做
各位记住了
千万千万不要一场来做一个空的资本体
对吧我好对就是
我要做资本体我要通过资本体发较资负
你想什么呢
反过来
让资本体从作为一个全新的资金
你真正应该成练的是
你的真实经营
因为那个东西是没有办法负质的
对吧你比如说好多人
好多人
如果我在视频报了一会儿
发现是拿我的那个
门来把他出现的时候结果那好的那样不留下
这不是胡子格的吧
对不对
你再帮我做免贝的宣传
最绪的东西
就是你的情感那个东西是没有办法抄袭的
AI一个刚才捡他去备他就是这么一个东西
所以各位你想想一下你真的找到一个
当时你偷偷有感触的一个打扼人
有个困难
然后你的什么
打了很有很有然后讲到你的那个情绪
你当时那个状态你经过了很长时间
你才把他搞定
对吧
然后我现在问你
如果你能过从来让你花点钱
你上来就能学会一些方法
然后他问我这个困难
你愿意
如果愿意那个就是你气耗的
第一条视频
我告诉你记得方法
首先第一个
真的花点时间把你过了就是数个一下
看看你都有那些困难的一些困境
考了你很有很有
你当时真的是偷偽偷的难受
然后
好长时间
长时的各种各样的方法
最后你把它通过了
找这么
几个
好好地回一下那都是财富
第二
然后你把当时的那个长就你的情绪
你当时的那个装裁那个细节
你后来怎么解决到你把它
发出来
把到朋友圈发到推特这种
没有什么压力的地方进行测试
看一下
如果有人的评论
我的狠狠论是
我靠这不就是我吗
我也经历过
我狠论他就有这样的经历而且有这样的情绪
我能问你到底是怎么做的
就这样
这是第二个
这是设施
这三部是什么
不算
你当时是怎么做的
你是怎么想的
最后你用的什么方法
说出来
就拍这个
你会发现你刚才不想被搞的
都是这些事情要什么搞的
你需要表演吗你不需要啊
这个你硬着情绪自然而然就就有的呀
对不对
中间卡住了说话可不
我告诉你在全都是家事上这个真实的
你们见过这种演讲吗
你看这个人就不会演讲
但是他讲那个故事就特别的真实是你会
你会吸引你会发现他要是会演讲
反而不好
为你们了这就是你其豪的第一头视频
那有人说我没有经历怎么办
我发现每次假门都会有人在下半个角度都没有演说
我没有就会怎么办
麻烦你你去经历一下好不好
你的人说是干嘛来来做自媒体的
记住这一会
不要去做一个空的自媒体
反过来
让自媒体帮助你输造一个
全新的自行